the leader came down the aisle just a
few rows in front of me he just took
somebody out of a an aisle seat
and marched him back up the plane
negotiated over him for a
half an hour or so and then he shot him
and he threw him out the plane
[Music]
I grew up in London I'm one of four
children my
mother was a doctor my father was a
Methodist minister I was
very studious
yeah I was I was the the nerd of the
family
and Peter your brother I know he's a big
part of your story
um can you talk about what happened to
him
my brother Peter was he trained as a
doctor but his first love was rock
climbing and as a as a doctor he was
quite in demand to go on Expedition so
he went to on an expedition to Everest
in 1980 they didn't get up it
um but they tried and in 1983 he went to
climb K2 an expedition with Doug Scott
and Al Rouse and a few other famous
climbers
and they were practicing
uh going to altitude on a mountain
called broad Peak which is very high
it's over 8 000 meters but it's
technically regarded as very easy he was
climbing with somebody called Greg child
who's since become a very very famous
climber and on the Summit Ridge
Greg started feeling ill Peter as the
doctor said we need to get you down
and so they turned around and started
down and as they went down
Greg got better and Peter got worse and
in the end
Greg was lowering him rope lengths by
rope length in the dark
um
they got to the top camp at um two in
the morning got Peter into a sleeping
bag but he died in the night died of
extreme altitude sickness pulmonary
edema
how old was Peter
he was 30. he was just about six years
older than me
um so it's it's always been slightly
strange when I became his older brother
as it were
um I always looked up to him as my big
brother
I had just taken my final exams as a
chartered accountant and I guess I was
probably going to just sort of carry on
with working in an accountancy firm
and suddenly with Peter gone that didn't
seem acceptable he had always gone off
to the ends of the Earth and come back
with amazing Stories and amazing
pictures and
I felt that I ought to be doing that now
that he wasn't there to do it and I had
had this this Daydream that I would go
to the bottom of his last mountain and
say goodbye to him and suddenly I had to
actually
say well yes I'm going to do it I I
hadn't thought that it was in any way
possible that I would walk to the bottom
of broad pick where I knew Peter was
still buried up the mountain
we were up in the mountains I guess for
about
five weeks I think and then it was time
to come home and we it took us another
week to walk out of the mountains
and when we got to the edge of
civilization which is a town called
skadu in Northern Pakistan
um I found some mail waiting for me that
had not got up the mountain and it said
I was expecting back at work the
following Tuesday
so I said goodbye to everybody and
caught an internal flight from Islamabad
down to Karachi stayed the night in the
airport hotel
and headed off to the airport at about
three o'clock in the morning
on the 5th of September
I was so happy to be going home it was
uh
it was a great feeling
plane was a little bit late coming in
from Mumbai and then a couple of small
mini buses took the
first in business class people out to
the front steps up the plane
bottom of the steps there was a little
guard of Honor a couple of Pan Am
employees somebody from the airport and
of course a soldier a soldier with Lee
Enfield rifle standing to attention in
his uniform
you think nothing of of this
um so I walked up the stairs the flight
attendant at the top of the stairs
indicated that I should go back to a
seat a few rows back
seat 13B
and I heard a noise in the second
doorway where the economy class people
were coming on and I looked up and over
there was a man struggling with a flight
attendant and he had a pistol in his
hand and he had his arm around her neck
she had a intercom in her hand and they
were struggling to and fro and this man
was dressed as a Pakistani he had what's
called a patani suit on a sort of baggy
cotton shirt baggy cotton trousers
little round glasses and
I just stared at him and I didn't
think of running away or going to help
or anything at all I was just staring at
him thinking that's a man with a gun
so I looked round to the doorway that I
just come in by and there was a man in
uniform
he had a great big rifle he looked to me
like a security guard and I had what I
think is a fairly typical civilian
reaction in this circumstance I thought
he's on my side the other guy's the bad
guy
I'm in the way
um but then a moment later things
started to go wrong I was you know I was
telling myself that this is all right
there's a perhaps a problem outside the
plane there's one person who's who's got
on the plane who's a problem but then
the soldier was shouting at the flight
attendant to close the door and when she
didn't he threatened her with the gun
and that didn't seem right
and then he said
where's the captain in that little delay
they the pilots escaped the pilots were
warned by the flight attendant of the
second doorway that there was a hijack
going on
they bailed out of a hatch in the top of
the cockpit and we were stuck on the
ground
but the hijackers once they'd found that
the pilots had gone they were obviously
this was a big setback from them they
they wanted to fly somewhere
um so they were
um
angry and they shouted everybody put
your hands up
they moved the first and Business Class
People Back Down the plane
so they could compress everybody into
the
um into two and a half cabins there's
jumbo jet it had about 380 people on
um and
the strange thing about it was it was
just very quiet we were sitting for
quite a long time with our hands in the
air
um and then there were there were
announcements we were allowed to lower
our hands onto our head and then lower
our hands into our laps as long as we've
made no sudden movements all the
announcements were made by the flight
attendants female voice saying ladies
and gentlemen do not make any sudden
movement or you will be shot
what were the hijackers doing in this in
this period when you were just sitting
I was convinced there were
a lot of them
um I I thought that there must be four
or five
um standing around the cabin in fact
there were four in total on the plane
one of them was up at the front door one
of them if I just leaned out slightly
and slowly not making any sudden
movement I could see him standing by the
curtain between the economy class and
the and the business class they were
negotiating I guess I mean the leader of
the front door was was trying to
um was trying to get a pilot that's what
he wanted
um but mainly they just stood there and
watched us and they made us pull the
blinds down the people who are sitting
by the windows so that we were sealed
off nobody outside could see and we
couldn't see out
and I thought
I will do what I'm told
and I will keep my head down and I'll
try and remain inconspicuous
I have to say that trying to think of
something to cheer myself up I thought
surely they'll be after Americans
and then
because he wasn't getting anywhere in
his negotiations the leader came down
the aisle just a few rows in front of me
he just took somebody out of a an aisle
seat
and marched him back up the plane
um negotiated over him for a
half an hour or so and then he shot him
and he threw him out the plane
and so that was the first man to die
were you fearing for your life
I was still telling myself that I would
go home at that point I thought
they will not pick on me if I do what
I'm told you know I'm I'm
minding my own business I'm down in my
seat I felt quite safe really
the next announcement was ladies and
gentlemen will Mr Michael John please
come to the front of the plane
for a moment I was just thinking
how why why have they picked me it must
be me
and I couldn't I couldn't get my head
around it at all
and I tried to think of some reason
other than they want to shoot me but I I
couldn't think of anything that was
remotely convincing so I stood up
with what might well have been my last
words which were for sake and walked
towards the front of the plane
and standing by that front door the the
leader had now taken his shirt off he
was a
a big a big guy he was probably six foot
three
um he looked like a soldier he'd got
this gun hanging around his neck on a
crepe bandage and he had two magazines
stuck together with sticky tape
and he had my passport in his hand and
as I walked towards him he said
you were Michael John Thaxton
I said yes
I said where are you from
I said I'm from London and he it seems
he's actually checking that the right
person has come forward it's it's just
bizarre
um and
um he told me to kneel in the doorway
and I had
um
gone from thinking well somebody will
probably get shot today but it doesn't
have to be me to
it's obviously going to be me you know
like I I couldn't think I still can't
think of any way out of this this is um
This Is the End
but I just I knew how awful it had been
for my family when my brother died and
now it was happening again
and I said to him
please don't hurt me my brother died in
the mountains my parents have no one
else
and he simply waved the hand as if to
say I'm too busy for that and
push my push me down
um so I was kneeling behind the door
with my hands on my head
um and he stood one of the flight
attendants in the crack of daylight with
the door just opened on the tilt
and she spoke with a megaphone to a man
who was standing on the runway
and he got her to say if anyone comes
near the plane if any U.S troops come
near the plane we will kill one body
immediately
and the man below he came back with
um
an offer he said there's a member of the
Pan Am ground crew on board who can
operate the cockpit radio and if you
speak to us on the cockpit radio then we
can withdraw everybody from around the
plane I could just about hear
some talking in a foreign language
coming down the stairs from from the
cockpit but I had no idea what they were
what they were saying and that's sort of
got me to thinking about the hijackers
and I decided
that I didn't want to die frightened of
them and I didn't want to die angry with
them
and so I had this
idea that if the leader came down the
stairs and said I'm going to shoot you
now I would offer to shake his hand
and then I wasn't frightened of him
um
there wasn't anything he could do to me
that I hadn't already
dealt with in my head
so all through the day I spent
my time at that front door at the bottom
of the stairs
for most of the day
the four seats behind the door were
occupied by these four female flight
attendants and
they had witnessed the man being shot
um
half an hour before me being called
forward
um
they were
I would say magnificent
and they kept everyone calm that was the
other extraordinary thing the way that
they made all of the announcements
through the day
they were the voice giving us this
chilling message you know but always
ladies and gentlemen
with never a Tremor it was never
never a note of panic because I think if
there had been a note of panic then then
everybody would be
um really
uh even more frightened than they were
much later in the day I was woken up by
somebody kicking my feet
um and he said up up move move and I
stumbled to my feet and thought it's
darker and hotter something was wrong
with the electrics the air conditioning
had gone the music had stopped playing
the lights were going down
and they put me back with the others I
was marched down the aisle I went
through the door I saw a window seat
just in near where I'd been sitting
before
an unoccupied window seat and I pushed
my way into it and sat down
and got as low as possible and I I just
was telling myself I'm back with the
others I stand the same chance as
anybody
but you could tell that something was
going to happen it was
it was getting very dark and very hot
and and just tense
and then when it was completely dark
what I remember is just bang
and
somebody had thrown a hand grenade I was
thinking
is that hand grenade surely hand grenade
would be louder than that I I've never
heard of angry before but while I was
still thinking that there was automatic
gunfire from the front of the plane the
Kalashnikov being emptied into the front
rows of the passengers and then a
classic off at the back of the plane and
then from the front of the plane because
he changed the magazines over and fired
again and then from the back of the
plane
and they threw six hand grenades around
the cabin
and when that was done
what I remember is that it was quiet and
I felt for the man next to me uh in the
dark and looked up got my head up a
little bit and I could see on the far
side of the plane it was all dark but
there was a different color of dark and
it was door shaped and I said to this
man I said they've got the doors open
come on we've got to go and he pushed me
back and said no no we're staying keep
stay down stay down stay safe
um I wasn't having this I I thought it
would burn I knew that it would be
fueled up to fly to Frankfurt and
um I didn't want to go that way I'd had
enough I got up into the into the aisle
and I saw the exit just behind me was
open
so I went and jumped down onto the wing
and it was dark now there were no lights
anywhere so I had this idea that I would
slide off the back of the wing dangle
from my fingertips and drop what I
assumed would be a few feet to the
ground
um and I went off the back of that Wing
at some speed there's nothing to hang on
to and and it is a long way down
um it's like jumping off the roof of a
house not a not not out of an upstairs
window
but I landed in a heap on the tarmac
pick myself up and ran away
I can remember
looking back over my shoulder at the
plane as I was running away from it
silhouetted against the night sky
and thinking
this is a dream I'm going to wake up in
a minute I'm going to be back on that
plane
um
there's
that this can't be real
and that's that thought stayed with me
for quite a little while
and I found
some other passengers near some
buildings and we all piled into a
stalker but slammed the door and sat
there for half an hour saying shh to
each other
so when the when the soldiers found us
in this store cupboard they took us the
terminal building and and all these
passengers were Milling around and they
were obviously worried that there might
be hijackers mingling among them which
there were they they found a couple of
hijackers trying to pretend to be
passengers
so it was chaos it was chaos eventually
two days later Pan Am sent another plane
to bring us back to Europe
um I arrived back in London on Sunday
night
was reunited with my family
Anna what point did you learn who the
hijackers were and what their intentions
were
so I found out at some point that this
was the Abu nidal organization who a
mercenary terrorist outfit
um
and they had been paid and found out
much later by Colonel Gaddafi to cause
some pain for the Americans out of
Revenge for the bombing raid that Ronald
Reagan had ordered earlier that year on
Libya and
um
only much much later we heard that they
had intended to crash the plane if
they'd had a pilot
the intention was to fly it over Israel
and and crash it somewhere blow it up
um
and
15 years before 9 11 that was their plan
I felt very lucky that I was
not one of the 20 or more people who
died
um 100 people injured
so I think for maybe two years
afterwards I used to think about it
a bit every day I I wasn't sort of not
in fear but just it would go over and
over in my mind you know this happened
and then that happened and it's probably
a couple of years later that I I
realized
that I hadn't thought about it all day
and it was the 5th of September
um and it was the anniversary and it it
um it hadn't hadn't occurred to me
the hijacker that chose to spare you
um did you find out the reason why he
did so
so one of the things that I had wondered
about all these years was why they put
me back with the others and
um
I had seen the hijacker in 2004 he was
put on trial in America and he had said
that he would answer questions
um that that he felt that the
the victims of his hijacking had the
right to ask questions if they wanted to
anyway we ended up waiting for him to
call me
um in my kitchen
um last year and
when he came through he sounded very
friendly he said oh Mike my old friend
is good to speak to you
um which was odd
and and so my first question was why did
you put me back with the others at the
end of the hijack why did you not just
shoot me and he said
ah it was what you said about your
brother
you said brother was killed or died or
something and it touched my heart
and I was astounded
um in all the years that had never
occurred to me because I mean at that
moment that was
when they first called me forward
um I didn't think he was listening to me
at all the idea that he would remember
that 12 hours later when they were about
to shoot people
had not occurred to me that's a good
feeling
that
um it's
um
it's quite an emotional feeling
um but uh
I was glad to know it
you know having wondered all these years
what what the reason was
but I don't think of him as the man who
spared my life
I think of him as the man who killed all
those other people
and just one more question and how does
it feel talking about this all these
years later like what kind of emotion
does it evoke in you now
sometimes the details
um catch me a little bit and I think
that was you know that was me and I was
going to be shot and those are real
other people who did get shot sometimes
I can just tell it as a story that
happened to somebody else
and that that I think is probably
the way that I have dealt with it is to
be able to tell it as a story
and it is a good story and I came out at
the other end of it which I didn't
expect to do
[Music]
the first bullet I received on the face
I still remember that I screamed I
screamed really loudly because
that was probably one of the first
bullet that broke my teeth and my
maxilla and that pierced through my face